Let's think about some of the first
things we would need to build
an application.
Like a real estate listing site.
First, we need to point
out locations on the map.
We're going to start off by mapping our
listings using lat-long coordinates.
We'll learn how to get coordinates
from addresses later in the course.
In order to keep this simple, we'll
just make one point on our map at first.
Within our initialized function,
we're going to create one lat-long.
We'll use the syntax seen here, which
is creating a lat-long literal object.
This point is in Tribeca.
Next, how do we make
it appear on the map?
We can use the little universally
recognized icon called a marker.
Markers are objects which can be
constructed either in the initialized
function or upon an action,
like clicking a button.
Let's create a super simple marker,
showing our first listing
at this point in Tribeca.
We're creating a new marker instance
using the google.maps.Marker object.
All the marker needs to know,
is the map that it should appear on and
where it should appear,
which is our point that we just created.
We'll also give the maker a title, which
will appear if we hover over the marker.
There are a bunch more things
that we could specify.
We can make it draggable, so that when
it appears, the user can move around.
We could specify an animations so
that it doesn't just appear on the map,
it drops, for example,
let's test this out.
There's our marker, but a point
on a map doesn't do us much good.
We have to tell the users
what they're looking at.
Let's check out how to display some
information about the marker, next.